terrible lie right it's it's such a
terrible lie to
to act that out to demonize your your
fellow citizens that way it's
unbelievably dangerous and
we got to stop doing things like that
you know and
all of us have to stop doing things like
that
right that may be at the bottom of it
what you mean there's so many ways that
this can be taken and i think that what
well it's difficult to say what's at the
bottom but one of the predominant
factors may be personalized
personal lies not personalized
yes i believe that i i really do believe
why why do you say that
right
see if you watch
the film toward the
fourth section i believe i split it up
into chapters and in the fourth section
it becomes much more philosophical which
was one of the reasons why i started it
because i happen to like puzzles and
philosophy it's one of the reasons i
went into math i like abstract thinking
so i tried to make a case about
lies and how lies spread now there's one
obvious route to take that with memes so
you talk about memes and how memes
spread so you don't want to pollute that
because that comes back to affect you if
you care about yourself first of all so
maybe you shouldn't care about yourself
so much
as for
i see something i was exploring and i'm
not quite sure is it possible to tell a
lie without lying to yourself that seems
on the face of it yes all right well i
don't think so well
it seems like psychological
well there's psychological evidence
though that you you can't well here
let's let's dig into that a little bit
so yeah you tell a lie to yourself and
you think well i know the difference
it's like well
don't be so sure about that so here's
one experiment that and that's an
example so imagine that i give a group
of people a
scale that measures their political
belief about a certain issue
maybe the reality of climate change or
or the unreality of climate change for
that matter doesn't matter and then i
get those same people to write an essay
of 500 words
outlining the contrary position
and they know they're just doing it
because it's part of the experiment but
then they come back a week later and i
give them the same political belief
scale
and what's happened is their beliefs
will have shifted substantially towards
the side that they argued for
okay so why well first of all
a lot of your so-called beliefs are
really low resolution
they're just heuristics they're like
single pixel images you haven't thought
it through very carefully imagine maybe
you know more than the average person
because of your background but imagine
how much you know about how a helicopter
works you know do you know what a
helicopter is yes no you don't if you
had to draw one it would look like a
four-year-old druid you know you know
what it you can identify the shape in
two dimensions you know it flies that's
about it you couldn't fix one you
certainly couldn't build one so in a
real sense you don't know anything about
a helicopter except what you need as
someone who's never around helicopters
to know and and most things are way more
complicated than helicopters even though
they're plenty complicated and so you
think that you know something when you
think you know it but then you detail
out a counter argument and it turns out
that you've provided more detail in the
counter argument that you had in your
argument to begin with
and so that shifts your cognition
towards what you argued for
well if you think that doesn't happen to
you when you're lying well you're you
don't know anything about how you work
and then the other thing is well
virtually no one thinks that lying is
acceptable morally when it comes right
down to it there might be specific
exceptions to that now and then
and so if you lie you're going to tilt
what you believe towards the lie because
that will
lighten the
ethical load that you carry it'll reduce
cognitive dissonance that's one way of
terming it
and so and then you can't keep track of
your lies and so that's a big problem
and they tangle up your thoughts and
then also let's say a whole bunch of
people really like your lie
well then you know most of us all of us
thrive on attention
i mean children will misbehave to get
attention even if it's negative
attention if they can't get it any other
way
and so
you lie and you you put it out on
twitter and you know 10 000 people like
it and then you think well wait a sec
probably i believe that because look at
how positively it was received and some
of that's actually
socially positive right i mean if you
say something a lot of people respond to
it positively
that might be a good reason for you to
think that way a bit more right because
the fact that you want social approval
isn't only an index of your cowardice
it's also an index of your desire to be
productive and to fit in and to have
people like you and all of that and so
lies
they just warp things to a tremendous
degree and if you think you're smart
enough to keep your lies separate from
your truth and then one final issue is
well let's say you lie 20 of the time
well doesn't that mean that you're
practicing to become 20 a liar and don't
you think you're getting better at that
you you become what you practice
and then don't you think that'll
interfere with your ability to
distinguish between what you think and
what you don't think first of all and
also your ability to tell the difference
between truth and falsehood
and so and don't you think it'll make
you cynical about the nature of
humankind to observe yourself lying
you're certainly going to think other
people do it at least as much as you and
if they're bad people they do it way
more
it's just a rat's nest and you know i
became convinced a long time ago looking
at the totalitarian problem on the left
and the right that the most effective
way to deal with this fundamentally was
psychological and that what we need to
do all of us is to stop lying each of us
in our own lives
that's the solution we have to stop and
that partly that's because we're so damn
powerful now i mean how many people have
watched your podcasts do you think
they're in terms of views now obviously
that's a there are multiple views for
one
video
millions almost seven or so seven or
eight million
okay so how powerful might your lies be
right
right and i mean each of those million
people is connected to a thousand other
people
so
that's a billion people that you're two
steps away from at least
now here's something else that i was
thinking about when we
right now we're speaking to one another
in podcast form so in some sense we're
copying this you can think of this
archetypically in some sense we're
copying podcasts by doing so when one is
playing rock music
one is copying rock in some because no
one speaks with a twang where do you
develop that you're copying something
then i thought well how far can you take
that when you're doing art in general
what are you copying okay how far can
that be taken how about if you're right
man now you've got exactly it right how
about if you're simply living laying
there
what are you copying
is by simply existing and living is that
a reflection of that what you're copying
is god's essence in some manner
that is abstracted completely i don't
think there's any difference i don't
think there's any difference between
imitation and worship
they're the same thing
that's why the eastern orthodox types
lay such emphasis on the imitation of
christ
well you should worship well pajo he
says well that means enthusiastically
celebrate
right raised to the highest position
well then you imitate that you imitate
that which is of most value
you imitate hopefully right what else
would you want to do
have you thought much about
self-fulfilling beliefs
you'd have to be worse okay here's the
reason why i say that imagine now
i i believe you outlined this too we've
talked plenty about maps so let's
imagine it's literally like a map just
for simplicity you you construct the
world so you have a world view and it
looks like a top-down view of a
of when you're buying an apartment and
you see the ground layout so imagine
that you're constructing a world view
when it comes to self-fulfilling beliefs
that's extremely interesting to me
because it means there are parts of
reality on that map
that whatever you project to be there
will be there
so let's say i think there's a toilet in
there you're right if you don't think
there's a toilet in there there's
there's not so there are parts of your
map that are always correct no matter
what you think about yeah well okay oh
well okay i would i would turn that a
little bit i would say
this is something kierkegaard talked
about at least to some degree
imagine that there are only things that
you can find out by doing them
so there are there you can't validate
the hypothesis you can't test the
hypothesis without acting it out
so let's say
you decide that you're going to tell the
truth well how what evidence is there
that you should do that well
who knows there's evidence that you
should lie it works in the short term it
might be to your benefit in the short
term i mean maybe if you deceive some
girl she'll sleep with you you know it's
like why not do that
well
you can't collect the facts you know in
some sense
no not in this simple manner well let's
say you decide to
tell the truth as carefully as you can
well then you're going to have a certain
kind of life
and you're not going to have that life
unless you do that and so you won't even
get access to the data unless you
take the steps and that's partly why
faith is necessary especially in an
endeavor like that you have to decide at
some fundamental
level right you know maybe you're
scattered all over the place it's
interesting when christ comes back in
the book of revelation
and he's the judge so he's separating
the damned from the saved let's say
um
he says something very strange he says
if you are neither hot nor cold i will
spit you out of my mouth he actually
says vomit it's so it's a disgust
reaction
and it's it's it's this idea that
it's the worst thing is to play both
sides against the middle
you know
that sometimes you'll lie and sometimes
you'll tell the truth you know you won't
commit to something because you want it
both ways and that's the worst possible
well so let's say you commit to lies
well maybe you'll find out pretty
quickly that that's a hell of a thing to
do and learn what if you don't commit
not sorry sorry yeah yeah go ahead i was
gonna say what if you don't commit not
because you believe that you know what's
what's correct and you'd like to lie but
because you simply don't know yeah well
that's what's going on
yeah yeah yeah that's that's a different
that's psychologically that's a whole
different thing i would say
uh well the real damage comes when you
know what you should do and then you
decide not to do it anyways yeah you
know violate your conscience yeah yes it
is the same thing and if you practice
that you're you're going to be in hell
and
you're probably going to drag if there
are a number of people along with you if
you have your druthers
so i feel comfortable speculating
because i don't mind sorry to enter i'm
so sorry that i keep interrupting oh man
it's my you're not don't be sorry about
it okay let me say this let me say that
it's fine i i also i don't know if it's
true that you temporarily get what you
want per se when you lie and the reason
is it depends on what you want now
obviously everything depends on
everything you can always say that it
depends on so and so but the reason i
say that is that
it's meritous in some sense you think
you want object x and then it turns out
that you don't when you get it so i
remember in pirates of the caribbean i
could be misremembering this but there
are some gold i think i'm completely
[Music]
generalizing this but let's imagine
there's some gold
gem that they wanted and it glows and
this guy's like there's only one in the
world that's unique i want this he
eventually goes through this whole
journey he finds it and then he says oh
you know what then he's happy until he
gets to this island where there's
millions it just
as far as the eye can see there are
these gold gems and it just stops he's
like why did i go through all this for
that
and in some sense i'm wondering
hmm
this is the majority of religious texts
telling us you think you want so-and-so
what you actually want is this and in
that way we can say that even the
atheist we can even say that the atheist
ultimately wants god even the serial
killer ultimately wants god well that's
it that's yeah yeah they're distractions
i can't wander down the road with you at
the moment because i'm getting tired but
um i'd like to say one thing about that
deceit issue again and maybe we could
close if you lie
to a girl and she sleeps with you
sure why aren't you a rapist
and is that actually what you wanted
right because you're you're it's false
pretenses like if you could get away
with it
yeah well so then all of a sudden you
don't have well maybe what you want in
your soul of souls is
you know
the
sexual encounter you'd have in paradise
you know you want love you want
companionship you want a maternal
embrace you want eroticism you want deep
personal contact you want eye to eye
communication that's all part of this
fantasy you know then you deceive
to get it and then you get it well no
you don't because you're a deceitful
rapist
and so what do you get well you get the
corruption of your soul and
the the contamination of the thing that
you want and need most desperately and
that the entire human
endeavor depends upon